you
it's a good question because I think it
is there is there are two things about
it number one is there's no
straightforward recipe but there are
things that we recognize we can do I
think number one it's to wreck to
understand that making the system work
well is something that we're only
starting to grapple with medicine has
been about parts it's been about having
a great drug a great doctor it has only
in the last few years started to become
about making all of that fit together as
well as possible and the most important
role I think that patients play is
they're the only ones that see when
things are falling through the cracks
you see one specialist and then another
specialist but they don't talk to each
other and what they're telling you
doesn't make sense or fit together a
third of patients by the end of their
life have 10 or more specialists in
their care and we're not very good at
knitting all of that together and so I
think the most important part the
patient plays is not being passive about
their part on the team they are we're
not great at drawing out the patient
we've wanted the patient to be passive
and and not so involved just do what we
say but the more we have different
people involved what we tell people is
contradictory it doesn't always help
them the way it should and as we get our
act together I think what we're learning
is the patient's play a key role
one thing that I tell people is if you
have a sick family member don't leave
them alone in the hospital even when
there are visiting hours where you know
you're supposed to go home I'll tell
people find any way you can to stay
anyway because when you're sick is the
last moment when when as a patient
you're able to fend for yourself and the
family member is often the person as
shifts change and different people come
and go we'll be the ones to convey you
know my dad actually seemed sicker than
he did yesterday you'll be surprised
about the extent to which just having
those kinds of eyes and ears are missing
with the slew of people coming and going
so I I know it can be unnerving it's
sort of like when the effort to trap
terrorists falls through and the
passenger has to be what the one to
tackle the of the terrorists trying to
light the bomb on the plane in a certain
sense for an extremely complex system of
care to work well we all have to be part
of the equation we in medicine have to
be willing to hear from patients he'll
challenges we sometimes have to be
willing to push back it's actually on
that one here's the reason why we're
doing it this way but it's becoming a
group effort in order to get things
right
you